Awesome.
Well, hi everyone. My name is Dominic. I
work on developer experience at OpenAI
and I'm excited to spend the next two
hours to talk to you all about voice
agents. Um, the QR code was already on
the slides. If you just entered the
room, you want to try to download the
dependencies as soon as possible. So,
head over to that QR code or to that
starter repository and follow the
instructions to install. That might take
a while with the internet right now. So,
please do that as soon as possible. You
have like 15 minutes of me rambling
about stuff before we get started with
uh with actually coding.
Um, so I said we're going to talk about
voice agents. I want to first put
everyone on the same page because I know
we all have different uh definitions of
agents and there's going to be a lot of
definitions flying around at this
conference naturally. Uh so when we're
going to talk about agents, we're
talking about systems that are going to
accomplish tasks independently on behalf
of users and most importantly um they're
going to be essentially a combination of
a model that is equipped with some set
of instructions that then has access to
tools that can both be used to work on
that goal. And then all of that is
encapsulated into a runtime to manage
that life cycle. And that's an important
definition because uh today we launched
the OpenAI agents SDK for TypeScript. If
you've heard of the one for Python,
today we basically released the
TypeScript equivalent. Um and so we're
going to use that and it maps those
exact patterns. So, if you're unfamiliar
with the agents SDK, it's basically a
SDK that provides you with an
abstraction based on the best press
practices that we learned at OpenAI to
build agents. Um, and they it comes with
a couple of different base foundational
features including things like handoffs,
guard rails, streaming input and output
tools, MCP support, built-in tracing, so
you can see actually what your agents
did and how they interacted with each
other. And then additionally to those
features that are coming from the Python
SDK, the SDK we launched today in
Typescript also includes human in the
loop support with resumability so that
if you need to wait for human approval
for a while, you can deal with that. And
most importantly, native voice agent
support. What that means in practice is
you can use that same those same
primitives that we already have in the
agents SDK and you can build voice
agents with that that handle handoffs
have output guard rails to make sure
that the agent is not saying things it's
not supposed to. uh tool calling,
context management, meaning keeping
track of the conversation history so you
can use it in other applications and
built-in tracer support um so that you
can actually replay conversations,
listen to the audio of the user and
properly debug what happened. Plus
native interruption support. If you've
tried to build interruptions, you might
know how hard this is. If you haven't,
be glad you don't have to. um both
WebRTC and websocket support meaning
it's actually can communicate both on
the uh on the server for things like
Twilio communicate like phone call voice
agents or directly in the client in the
browser that's what we're going to use
today using WebRTC
but first why why would we be interested
in voice agents in the first place um
one of the things that I'm most excited
about is it makes technology much more
accessible to people. There's something
magical about being able to talk to a
voice uh to like a voice agent and just
have it like see it do things. It's also
um much more information dense. I can
convey information much faster, but also
it can contain a lot of information
through the type of tone and voice that
I'm using, the emotions. So, it's much
more information dense than sort of just
based basic text is. One of the cool
things is also it can act as like an API
to the real world. You can have a voice
agent go and like call a business for
you and like have a conversation with
them where maybe there isn't a there
isn't an API for that business.
And so when we talk about building voice
agents, there's essentially two types of
architectures that have emerged on when
building these. The first one is based
on your traditional textbased agent and
just sort of wrapping it into a chained
approach where we have a speech to text
model that is taking the audio and then
turning it into text so that we can run
our basic textbased agent on it and then
we take that and we uh run that agent
take the text output and run it through
a texttospech model to generate audio
that we can play. Again
this has a lot of strengths. One of the
most common reasons why we raise this is
it's much easier to get started with if
you already have a textbased agent. You
can take that wrap some audio around it
and you have something that you can you
can interact with. But uh the other
aspect is that you have full access to
any model. Text is the main modality
that any LLM has and so you can use
really any of the cutting edge models.
also gives you much more control and
visibility of what the model did by
being able to actually look into the
exact text that went in and out of the
model. But it also comes with some
challenges. Turn detection is one of the
one of the big ones where you need to
now take into consideration what did the
user hear by the time that they
interrupted some uh interrupted the
voice agent. Then translate that part
back into text. make sure that like your
transcript is appropriately adapted so
that the model doesn't think it told the
user something that it didn't. Um,
chaining all of these models together
adds latency on every possible level.
And so that's another big challenge. And
then you're losing some of that audio
context, right? You're transcribing the
audio. And if you've ever tried to
convey a complicated topic over a text,
you know it's a bit harder than dealing
the deal dealing with the same thing
using using your own voice.
And so an alternative to that chained
approach is a speechtoech approach where
we have a model that has been trained on
audio and then takes that audio uh to
directly interact on the conversation
and make tool calls. Meaning there's no
transcribing in the process. the model
can just natively deal with that audio
and that translates into much lower
latency because we're now skipping the
speech to text text to speech processes.
We can also now have much more
contextual understanding of the audio um
including things like tone and voice and
all of that leads to a much more natural
fluid uh level of conversation.
But there are some challenges with this.
One of the most common ones is reusing
your existing capabilities. Everything
is built around text. So if you already
have some of those existing capabilities
or a very specialized agent for a
certain task, uh it's harder to reuse
those. Also, dealing with like complex
states and complex decision making. It's
a bit harder with these models since
they've been really focused on improving
on the audio conversational tone, less
so on being very complic complex
decision makers.
But there is a solution that we can get
around with this. Um again taking
inspiration from what we do with
textbased agents, we can actually create
a um delegation approach using tools
where we have a frontline agent that is
talking continuously to the user and
then that one uses tool calls to
interact with much smarter reasoning
models like 04 mini or 03.
Uh actually let me at this point give
you a quick demo and see how the
internet goes here. Um, so I have a
real-time agent here that we build with
the agent SDK. It's going to be very
similar to what you're going to build
later on. Um, but when I start talking
to this,
hello there.
Hello there. How is the engineer going?
So we can now give it t like give a task
to like call tools that I gave it like
hey what's the weather today?
Let me check the weather for you. One
moment, please. Transferring you to the
weather expert now. Actually, I can
directly help you with the weather
information. Could you please specify
the location you're interested in? Oh,
yeah. What's the weather in San
Francisco?
So, you can see here it's actually
dealing with the interruption.
Enjoy the bright and pleasant day. Is
there anything else I can? No, that's
it. Thanks.
You're welcome. If you need anything
else, feel free to ask. Have a great
day. And so in a similar way, we can
actually trigger the more complicated
backend agents as well. So I have a tool
for this to handle refunds that will
call out to 04 mini and evaluate the
refund. So hey there. Um I have one more
thing. So I recently ordered this
skateboard that I tried to use and it
seems like I'm really bad at
skateboarding. So I want to return it.
Um, it is slightly a scratch though.
I'm here to assist, but it sounds like
you need customer service for that. I
recommend contacting the company where
you bought the skateboard. They can
provide you with the Looks like I didn't
add the tool. Maybe I did.
Oh, I asked for I didn't ask for a
refund. Um, let's try this once more.
Hey there. Um, I bought a skateboard
recently that I tried and apparently I'm
really bad at using it, so I wanted to
return it. It is slightly scratched, so
can you give me a refund?
Hello there. How is the
Hello there? How is the AI engine? The
joys of internet. Um,
hey. Um, I recently ordered a skateboard
from you and it uh
failed. Like I I can't use it. I'm
struggling to use it. It's slightly
scratched. Can you give me a refund,
please?
Hello there. How is the
I'm going to assess your request for a
refund. There we go. It is slightly
struggling with this like weird echo
that we're having here. your skateboard
arrived damaged and you're eligible for
a full refund, we'll process that for
you. All right. Um, but you can see here
that uh it was able to call that more
advanced tool and um actually process
that request. And one of the nice things
is that like while time to first token
is often a really important thing, the
longer a conversation goes, like your
model is always going to be faster than
the audio that has to be read out. And
so this this is like a really helpful
thing where by the time that the model
was able to say like, hey, I'm going to
check on this for you, it already had
completed that LM call to the 04 mini
model to get the response there.
All right. Um,
let me Oh, one more thing. Since we
talked about traces, one of the nice
things now is we can actually go back
here into our traces UI. And this launch
today, um, you'll be able to actually
look for any of your real-time API
cases, look at all the audio that it
dealt with, um, and all the tool calls.
So, we can actually see here that the
tool call was triggered, what the input
was, the output. We can listen to some
of the audio again
um, to understand what happened. And
then because both this and the backend
agent used the agents SDK, we can go
into the other agent as well, which was
the O4 mini one, which we can see here.
And we can see that it received the
context of the full past conversation,
the full transcript, um, as well as
additional information about the request
and then generated the response here. So
this allows us to then get a full
complete picture of like what happened
both on the front end and the back end.
Let's jump back into the slides and
cover a couple of more things before we
get coding. Um, and that's about best
practices. So, I would group when you're
group the best practices of like
building a voice agent into three main
things to keep in mind. Uh, the first
one is to start with a small and clear
goal. This is super important because
measuring the performance of a textbased
agent, you will hear a lot about evalu.
But with voice voice agents, it's going
to be even harder. So you want to make
sure that you're very focused on like
what is the first problem you want to
solve and keep it focused on that and
give it a like limited number of tools
so that you're fully centered on this.
The agents SDK makes this really easy
because you can then later on add
additional tools to additional agents
and deal with like handoffs between
them. Uh but this way you can kind of
really stay focused and make sure that
one of your use cases is great and then
hand off other ones to human agents for
example.
The second one is what I elaborated on
which is building evals and guard rails
very early on. Uh so that you can feel
both confident in what you're building
but also confident in um that is
actually working so that you can then
continue to iterate on it and know when
it's time for you to like grow the
complexity of your voice agent. Uh as of
today you can use the traces API the
trace dashboard for that. Uh but
alternatively, some of our customers
have even built their own dashboards
like Lemonade to really get an
end-to-end idea of the customer
experience and then even replay some of
these conversations with their agent as
they're iterating on it.
The other thing that I'm personally
super excited about with these models is
uh both our speech to speech model and
our text to speech model are generative
models meaning you can prompt them the
same way that you can prompt a LLM
around tone and voice and you can give
it emotions roles personality. Uh we
built this little micro site called
openai.fm. It's a really fun website to
play around with where we have a lot of
examples of different personalities and
how that uh that that style of prompt
can then change what is being read out
by our text to speech model. And so
that's a great way for you to not just
limit one second uh limit the experience
of your model
um or like the personality of your model
by the voice that you picked but also by
the prompt and instructions that you're
giving it. There was a question there.
Would you mind using the mic that is
right behind you just so that it's on
the recording?
Hello sir. So my question regards to the
previous slides on Lemonade. So you're
displaying how they have this dashboard
where they can show all of this. Is this
a dashboard that OpenAI provides and
Lemonade just integrates as like an
iframe or something? No. So in this case
they built their own um solution for it.
Okay. And does OpenAI then provides all
the JSON or the data structure that we
can just plug into the so the the way
the real time API under the hood works
is that you get all the audio data and
you can do whatever you want with that.
Basically, you're getting all the
necessary audio events. So you can use
those data structures. So we're not
storing them by default. You can use the
traces AP uh the traces dashboard. We
don't have an API for it yet, but you
can use the trace traces dashboard to um
get a a basic look of of that, but it's
not ifraable. But you mentioned it's
only audio data. This shows not just
audio, but also transcription and all of
that as well. Right. So, the the traces
dashboard, if we go back to it, um does
show
um
all of the transcripts and stuff as
well, as long as you have um
transcription turned on, which I don't
seem to have turned on for this
particular one. Um but it should like
you can turn on transcription and you
should be able to see the transcripts as
well. Okay. Thank you. You're welcome.
All right. Um let's go back to this. Um
the other part with it is as I said you
can prompt both the personality you can
also be very descriptive with the
conversation flows. One of our
colleagues um found that giving it
conversation states and so this JSON
structure is a great way to help the
model think through sort of what
processes and what steps it should go
through the same way that you would give
a human agent a script to operate on.
If you're struggling to write those
scripts though, uh we also have a custom
GPT that you can use to access that. And
I'll share all of those links and a copy
of the slide deck later on in the Slack
channel. So if you're in that, uh you
should be able to access those.
But with that, um that's primarily what
I wanted to talk through from a from a
slides perspective. So from here on,
what I want to do is um build with you a
voice agent. We'll see how that goes
with the internet. Um, also, if you have
headphones, now is a great time to bring
them out. It's going to be really weird
when we're all gonna talk to our own
agent. Um, but we're going to try this
and see how that goes. Um, so if you
came in later, please scan the QR code,
go to that uh GitHub repository, and set
that up. Install the instructions.
There's no code in it yet other than
like a boilerplate Nex.js JS app and a
um empty like package JSON that install
just like the dependencies that we
needed so that we are not all trying to
run npm install at the same time.
But what I want to do is build a first
agent. Um, so if you want, you can just
straight up copy the code that is on
here, but I'm gonna um actually go and
type it along with you all so that you
get a feeling for what's happening and
we have a good idea of like timing. So
if you want to take a picture now and
just code ahead, do that. And otherwise,
I'm going to switch over to my code
editor and we're going to do this
together.
Oh, and if you're running into trouble,
the Slack is a great way to post
questions that are technical questions
and a noop who's over there um is going
to try to help you. Um, alternatively,
raise your hand, but it's a bit easier
if you're just slacking the messages
there and we can kind of multi-thread
the problem. Um, all right, let's go and
build an agent. So if you clone the
project, you should see an index
uh.ts file. Go and open that and you
should be able to import the agent class
from the OpenAI/ aents package. That's
what we're going to use to create the
first agent. Yeah.
Oh yeah, good call. Um
Is that better?
Cool.
That seems a bit seems worse on my side
than yours, but I think as long as you
all can read that, I'll be fine. Um, all
right. So, what you what I want you to
do is go and import an agent. And we're
going to define our first agent. And as
I mentioned, um, primarily the an agent
has a like a few centerpieces. The first
one being a set of instructions on what
to do. So we can give it instructions.
I'm going to say you're a helpful
assistant. That's sort of the most
boilerplate thing you can do. We do need
to also give it a name and that's uh so
that we can actually keep track of them
in our traces dashboard.
I'm going to say my agent here. This can
be anything that helps you identify it.
And then we need to actually execute
this agent. So we can import a run
function here.
And then
we can await the run here. I'm going to
run this agent with just hello, how are
you? And then log out the results. And
with the results we get a lot of
different information because uh
essentially when we run an agent it's
going to do a lot of different tasks
from executing all necessary tool calls
if there are any to validating output
guard rails etc. But one of the most
common things that you just want to log
out is the final output. That's whatever
the last agent in an execution said. Um,
so in this case it's going to be uh a
set of text and then you should be able
to run npm start
um oh npm run start
and that should execute it and then you
should see something like this um
depending on what your model decides to
generate and by default this is going to
run gbt 4.1
um as the model but if you want
experiment with this. You can set the
model property here and we can set it to
for mini for example and then rerun the
same thing. So this is the most basic
agent that you can build. But one of the
things that really makes something an
agent is if it can execute tools. So we
can import a tool here.
We go and we can define a get weather
tool. Um,
one of the things here is you have to
specify what arguments the model is
going to receive. And one of the ways
that you can do this is through a tool
called ZOD. If you've never heard of it,
it's essentially a way to define
schemas. Um, and what we'll do is we'll
both use that ZOD schema to inform the
model on what the parameters for this
function call are, but we're also going
to use it to validate then what are the
actual arguments that the model tried to
pass in and do they fit to that schema.
So we get full type safety here if
you're a TypeScript developer and you
care about that. So in this case we have
um a get weather tool and then we can
give that tool to the agent and we can
change this to what is the weather in
Tokyo uh is what cursor wants to check.
So if I run this again,
let me move this slightly. We can see
it's going to take a bit longer now and
that's because it ran some tools. Um and
now it's telling me the weather in Tokyo
is sunny. And if you're wondering, well,
did it actually run a tool? We can go
into
our traces dashboard here
and look at the trace. We have a my
agent here.
And in there we can see it ran
tried to call the tool executed the tool
and got the weather in Tokyo sunny back
and then took the response to generate
the final response. So the traces
dashboard is a great way for you to see
what actually happened behind the
scenes.
How we feeling? Can I get a quick
temperature check? Are able are people
able to follow along? See Zeke is giving
a thumbs up there. So um all right so
this is a textbased agent. I wanted to
show you this just to get a bit familiar
with the um overall agents SDK so that
we can jump into building voice agents.
Uh the first one we're going to build or
like the first thing we need to
understand about a voice agent is the
slight differences between a voice agent
and a and a what we call a real-time
agent. Essentially, a real-time agent is
just a specialized version of an agent
configuration. There's just a few fields
you can't pass in, but they can be used
in what is a what's called a real-time
session because with voice agents,
there's a lot more things to deal with
than just executing tools in a loop. Um,
one of the most important things is you
need to deal with both the audio that's
coming in, uh, process that and then
like run the run the model with that and
then gener deal with the audio that's
coming out. But you also need to think
about things like guard rails, handoffs,
other life cycle things. And so the
real-time sessions are really dealing
with all of that. So let me show you how
that works. Um for this what we're going
to do is we're going to go in the same
project. There's a 02
and it has a page txt tsx in there. Um,
this is a Nex.js app that really I just
gutted to have like the bare minimum in
there, but this is a great way for us to
just uh build both the front end and the
back end part of the um voice experience
because this voice agent that we're
going to build is going to run in the
browser. In order to make sure we're not
leaking your API credentials, one of the
important things is you need to use an
ephemeral key. That is a key that is
shortlived and is going to be generated
by your server and handed off to your
client so that they can use that to
interact with the real-time API over a
protocol called WebRTC.
Um, for that you should see a token.ts
file in your repository that just calls
out to the real-time API to generate a
session and then return a client secret
which is that ephemeral key that we can
then use to authenticate with the SDK.
You do not have to do this if you're
building a real-time agent that is
running on your server. For example, in
the case of a Twilio app or something
else where you can just directly
interact with the
uh open AI API key. But if you're
running anything in the browser, then
you actually need to generate this
client key just so that you're not, you
know, giving your API key to the world.
So with that in here, we can actually go
and build our first real-time agent. So
similar to previously, we're going to
import a an agent class here, but in
this case, it's going to be a real-time
agent.
And we're going to import it from the
real time package
uh which is just a subpath in the same
package. So you don't need to install a
different package here. But now we can
define a real-time agent that works the
same way. We have a name, we give it
instructions.
Um, just sort of going with a default
suggestion here. And now we actually
need to connect that agent to a
real-time session. So I have a connect
button here for running this example.
Let me start it up here with npm run
start02. That command should be in your
readme as well.
Uh, it's going to start a development
server. And we can go over here, reload
this, and you can actually see
it just has like a little connect button
that right now doesn't do anything.
So, let's connect that up. I don't need
this anymore. Um, so let me just move
this to the side.
Um, so in this on connect function that
gets triggered whenever we press the
button, we want to deal with that
connected state. So
we're what we're going to do here is
we're first going to fetch that token.
And this code what this basically does
is it's going to import that server
action which is an next.js concept that
just makes sure that like this code is
going to run on your back end. If you're
using a different framework, you you
should be able to just go and fetch this
key from your backend server. Um, and
then once we have that token, we can go
and create a new real time session. So,
what we're doing here is we're going to
give it the first agent that should
start the conversation up. Uh, I'm going
to specify the latest model that we
released today along with the agents
SDK. This model is a if you've used the
real-time API before, it's an
improvement especially around tool
calling. It's much better on that front.
Um, we have a couple of different
customer stories on our Twitter if you
want to check that out. Um, and then I'm
going to give it not there. I don't know
why cursor insists on that. Um, the last
step that we need to do is we need to
connect to that session.
So, this is where we're going to give it
that API key so that the mo that we can
connect to the real-time session under
the hood
just so that it's easier for us to deal
with all of this. I'm also going to
close the session. But I've got one
thing here that is an oddity of
uh React. We do not want to generate
that session every time. So, I'm going
to on every rerender. So, I'm going to
create a what is called a ref here.
Again, if you're new to React. Um, this
basically is just a variable that's
going to persist through rerenders. So,
we need to slightly change this here
where we're going to assign that to
session.curren
so we can maintain that. And then that
also allows us to say if there is a
session.curren set, uh, we want to
actually close that connection when we
press the disconnect button. That just
makes sure that we're disconnected from
the audio again.
So, I'm going to leave that on the
screen for a second and then we can test
this out. But if you already typed this,
go into your browser, refresh, press
connect, and you should be able to talk
to your agent.
All right, let's try mine. Let me move
this to the other side so it's not
blocking your cut.
Hello.
Hi there. How can I assist you today?
All right. So, you can see um it's just
a few lines of code. We didn't have to
deal with things like figuring out how
to set up the microphone, how to set up
the speakers. By default, if it's
running in the browser, it will do deal
with all of that automatically. If you
do want to pass in your own microphone
source or other things like that, you
can do that as well. Um, if this is
running on a server, you have a um
both a
send audio function that allows you to
send an audio buffer in or you can
listen to the audio event which is going
to emit all of the audio buffers that
are coming back from the model so that
you can pass it to whatever your source
is.
Um,
so that's our first basic agent. Any any
questions so far?
H, can you send that code to the red?
Sorry, we want you to send the code. Can
you push it? Can you push it up? I can
push it. Yeah.
Good call. Thank you. Um,
all right. So, now that we have that,
let's go and actually give it a tool.
So, this is really where the benefit of
the um agents SDK comes in. We can
actually use that same tool definition
that we did earlier. Um, so I'm just
going to follow the autocomplete here.
We should be able to just give that tool
now to our agent
and save.
I need to import zod
again to do that schema validation. This
is especially important on the real time
side because the real- time model
currently do not does not support strict
mode. So the JSON might not fully comply
with your um
um schema unless you're running you're
giving us a zod schema and we'll go and
validate that this actually fits that
schema. So that makes your code a bit
easier. So with that we can go back.
Hey, what's the weather in San
Francisco?
The weather in San Francisco.
We can disconnect it here. Um, also this
does now deal with interruptions. So,
hey, can you slowly count to like 20?
Sure, I'll count to 20 for you. 1 2 3 4
5 Okay, stop.
Sure, I'll stop counting. How far did
you count?
I counted up to six.
It's pretty pretty close. It's always
hard with the timing to like perfectly
get it, but uh normally that's enough to
um deal with the context, but it is
super crucial to have that interruption
timing so that like your model doesn't
think it read out like the full customer
policy um but the customer interrupted
it halfway through, for example. Um all
right,
question. You don't have to um manage
all the events to actually do that
anymore? No. Um, so the the real- time
session will handle all of those events.
That is a great proxy to if you are
curious about these events um that
you're alluding to. What we can do is
listen to the
transport event
and let's do this later. Uh this will
log out all of the events that are
happening under the hood. So, if we open
the dev tools here and rerun this.
Hey, hey there. How can I help you
today? So, you can see all of the events
that normally you would have to deal
with are being dealt with, you still
have full access to them. So, you can
both read them, but you can also send
events yourself. So, it's going to
handle all of the things but continue to
par pass them on to you if you want to
do your own logic. On top of that,
I'm going to push that code for you so
you can pull it.
Cool. Um,
all right. Since we already have this
commented out code, the other part of
this that typically is a request that
you want to deal with is I want to show
like the transcript. I want to see what
sort of is being transcribed. And the
important thing here is I'm using the
word transcribe because even though the
speechtoech model is dealing with the
audio directly, um, and there is no
transcription step in between, by
default, we're going to transcribe all
of the conversation at the same time.
Um, you can turn that off if you want
to. Um, if you're using the API
directly, you have to actually turn it
on. Um, in the agents SDK, it's turned
on by default because it's such a common
request and it enables us to do a couple
of additional features that we'll cover
later on. But this is going to give us
that whole history every time. So, I'm
just going to um log that history here.
Or rather, I'm gonna There we go. import
that. I'm going to
set that as a variable. And then because
it's React, we can let's create a list
here. We're going to go over all of
this. I need to filter because it has
both tool calls and messages. And I only
want to show the messages for this. Um,
so should be able to does why I want
that. Um, let's see.
Close this. Refresh.
Hey.
Hello. How can I assist you today?
How's the weather today in San
Francisco?
The weather in San Francisco today is
sunny. Anything else you'd like to know?
So, you're automatically getting that
conversation. If you are interrupting
the model, one of the things that
happens is the transcript is going to
disappear. And that's because uh the the
model currently does not adjust that
transcript and instead it's going to be
removed and we're going to remove it
from that object as well just so that
you get the most accurate representation
and you're not thinking that like the
model read out a certain piece of text.
And again with everything that we're
doing here can actually go back into
traces and we can see that same
representation here with the weather
call and everything. So again helps with
the debugging.
Go briefly back to the slides. So we
covered we set up our first agent.
Yeah.
The question was how do you store the
conversation history? Um so it's
currently fully stored in memory. Um, so
basically there's going to be a bunch of
events that that I logged out that are
being emitted by the real-time API. All
of those are going to be sent over to
the client and then store it in memory
in a conversation like in just like an
array essentially. So you can do
whatever you want with that by listening
to that history updated event. So if you
do want to store it somewhere, you can
store it. Um the other part is the
traces part is automatically going to be
stored on the open AAI uh platform as
long as you both enable that tracing you
can disable it um by default in the
agent SDK is enabled and then um the
other aspect of that is if you are a ZDR
customer so a zero data retention
customer of open AAI you don't have
access to that traces feature um about
the conversation
Um, so the question was how much of the
like voice context, how much of the
previous conversation is being used. Um,
that's going to depend and sort of like
dealt with directly by the real-time
API. So like the real-time API when you
do start that session um that holds the
source of truth for that whole
conversation session. So what you're
receiving on the on the client side is
just a copy of whatever is happening at
that point. It's not the source of truth
of what we're going to adapt to pass
into the model.
Um the question is how does it work with
like the inference cost and like whether
you're passing like passing in that
whole conversation. Um, and Noob is
nodding. Um, he is the bigger expert
there. But yes, um, we're actually like
you can log the the like we're keeping
track of the usage. There's an event
that you can like log out to see your
token cost. Um, so you have an idea of
like what is being actually passed in.
So like with every if we're going back
here to this example, you can see these
response done events. Um I don't know
where is the
um shouldn't it be on the response done?
Uh it is being sent over. I just do not
know right now why it's not showing. Oh
there. So you can see here um it outputs
the detailed information of your tok to
token usage at any point in time. So
while you don't have like access to like
what is exactly what was passed into the
next response generation um you can keep
track of the cost as it's happening.
You're welcome. Uh yes. Do you there's a
microphone right over there that might
be easier than you yelling across the
stage to me. I I see that the format
that you're using is PCM16. Is there a
way in which we can modify the output
formats of the audio files so we can
save in memory? Um yeah, there are
different different audio modes that you
can use um including like for example u
law for that is like helpful for phone
calls for example.
Sorry, another question on the usage. Um
does that like final assistant response
roll up all the tokens from like all the
intermittent tool calls as well? Does
that make sense? Like the agent needs to
like kind of reason through and then
format tool calls. So I'm assuming it's
not just the output tokens for only the
assistant response, right? It like every
tool call is a response in general as
well. So like it it works the same way
that like the responses API works for
example. Okay. So like each right
because we're using this and we have
like tool calls and tool call outputs,
right? And I couldn't find the like
usage attribute on the tool call output.
Is it somewhere in those like raw events
that are outputed?
Do you do you know a new Okay, no
worries. I I know it's like kind of
early on. We can we can follow up
behind. Thank you. You're welcome. Uh
yeah. Do you want to head over to that
microphone that is right behind you? It
just makes it a bit easier.
Uh yeah, there's in the meantime just a
quick question. Can I go back to the
slides explaining the different modes of
the uh the audio agents like the text in
text out that's the first one. Oh yeah,
text to speech that's the second one.
Uh, I didn't get the third one. And uh
Oh, you mean this?
Yes.
Yes. It's uh when you just showed us the
GPT4 real time that one. Yeah. That
model is that uh this PPT this slide is
about. Yeah, exactly. So like where it's
like when we did the refund um it kind
of followed this pattern where it
performs a tool call like the like real
time API agent can perform tool calls.
It performed a tool call to trigger a
separate agent that was the refund agent
that in my case used 04 mini to execute
that task and then hand that back.
Okay, got it. Thanks. You're welcome.
Yes. Um I'm currently using like a
regular uh OpenAI agents. So what will
be the challenge that I will face when I
would when I want to change my regular
regular agents to realtime agents? So
there's a couple of different challenges
like one is like anything that you're
doing around latency like like anything
you're doing around um voice latency is
always king. So like you want to figure
out what are the best ways to actually
have a slide around this. Um like when
you when it comes to things like tool
calling, you want to find ways to do
things like buying yourself some time.
So you will typically see some prompting
around like announce what you're about
to do next um before you're doing it.
And that's to do that little trick
around uh while the while the previous
audio is still being read out, the agent
can already perform the tool call and
wait for the tool call to come back
because similar to a textbased agent,
the model can't do like can't receive
additional data as like like do another
thing. Um outside of like we can
interrupt the response but it can't
finish that response if that makes
sense. And so you want to do these sort
of like buying time. The other thing is
like if you're building a real-time
agent, the longer your prompt gets, at
one point it increases the likelihood
that it gets confused. So you want to
make sure you're properly scoping those
use cases and like through what what we
call handoffs where you have different
agents that are more spec scope to
specific steps in your experience.
Thank you. You're welcome.
Yes.
Yeah. So you're uh
Yeah. So the question is about memory.
Um basically
right now the the the
let me correct this. Um, when we go back
to this demo, what you're seeing here is
essentially just like a copy of the
events that we're receiving back. So,
this is like helpful as a visualization
of the history. Uh, that being said, the
actual like memory in the sense of like
an LM agent memory is the session
context that is happening on the
real-time API side. There are events
that you can use to update that. Um, we
actually have an update history event
that you can pass in what you want the
history to be. But what that does is
essentially like fire off events to the
real-time API to say like delete this
item from the history or add this new
item. Um, and you can give it a previous
item ID. So like you can for example
like slot messages into a specific spot
if you wanted to. Um, does that make
sense? But there's like no no like
advanced like long-term memory solution
like like you were alluding to. Cool.
Yes. Hi. Do you have tips for handling
input from low fluency users? Like say
someone who's just learning a language
and they have like multilingual input
and maybe broken grammar and their
pronunciation is not so good. Uh I don't
think I have any like best practices
right now that I could share. Can it
handle it just off the shelf or? Um, it
can handle like switching languages and
and things like that. Okay. But it might
not be able to handle low fluency.
Um, I don't know if we have any use
cases.
Yeah, we have we have some customers
that are like language learning
companies. So there there is some that
are using it that way. But I don't think
I have any like best practices that I
can share. Okay. Thank you. You're
welcome.
Sorry. Back in the code, is there a call
back for the interrupt and does it
include the last transcription? Um,
there is a call for the interrupt, but
uh there is no
um
there's no actual like event that
there's no parameter E that comes with
it or anything like that. No, there's
currently no um transcript. So what you
can do is if you're getting this, you
can call get history or something. Uh
there's just history. Um so like this
always is up to date. Um so you can you
have access in that moment. The the
thing that we do have is um for tool
called specifically
um you're getting some additional
context and that context has a
um history parameter that you can like
push into. Okay. Um it's more documented
in the in the documentation the API.
Okay. Great. Thank you. You're welcome.
Awesome. Um, let's move a bit on and
show a couple of other things. So, we
talked about tools. As I said, like one
of the benefits is you can reuse the
same syntax that you're doing with
textbased ones. Um, it's also a good way
for you to then communicate with your
backend systems using HTTP. um follows
sort of a um
general practice around like keeping
both the tool calls as low latency as
possible. like send out a tool like for
example if you know a task is going to
take longer, start the task, give it a
task ID and have the agent have a tool
to check on the status for example like
that helps getting back to it because
again while the tool call is going on
the model is sort of stuck. So you want
to you want to make sure to like get get
back to that as soon as possible. Um one
of the other things that you can do is
human appro uh uh human approval. I can
show you that quickly. There's
essentially a use uh it needs approval
that um you can either specify as a
function that will be evaluated before
the tool ever gets triggered. This is a
great way if you have like a more
complex
logic on I need approval for this. You
can also give it just straight up I
always need approval at which point
there is a
another event here. um
tool approval requested and then that
gets a
um event here. So we can do things like
um
good old prompt
um and then we can go and approve that
tool call again.
I don't know why the autocomplete is not
working.
Um,
proof.
There we go. And
why is it
Oh, this is wrong.
This is where I go into the docs because
I do not remember why this is
autocompleting the wrong way. But
everything I'm showing you is in the
docs. Um, so we can just
Oh, took the wrong thing. Right. The
first
There we go. Approval request.
And then we can do
approval request. Thank you. It's like
the classic thing when you're on stage
and you can't really
There we go. So, in this case, I'm just
going to always approve. But if we now
go in,
hey, um, can you tell me the weather in
Seattle?
So we can in that case approve it. It's
always going to approve right now
because I'm not actually checking the
status. But um that means you can build
like a human in the loop approval
experience.
This is really convenient especially if
you're running it in the browser and you
just want to have like a confirmation if
like the tool is hallucinating things
before the customer actually submits it.
And does it do it directly? kind of
actually say you okay if I do this or
not to do that and then do voice extra
voice so the the basically this is
happening so the question is does it
automatically do this like the what
we're doing and the reason why this is
separate is the model is asking for this
tool to be executed but we're
intercepting this um basically before
we're ever generating or executing the
response this is intentional so that
like you don't have to deal with like we
want you to think through why should
this tool need approval as opposed to
doing that somewhere halfway through
your tool execution and you have to like
deal with the consequence of rolling
back every decision that you've made for
example and so by default if this is
just needs true it cannot get past that
until the execution was approved at
which point it stores it in the context
that is stored locally and then bypasses
that security. So this is not happening
on the on the model level.
Um I'm going to remove that again.
Uh so the other thing we talked about
already but I want to show it in
practice is handoff. So a handoff is
essentially just a specialized tool uh
call that resets the configuration of
the agent in the session so that um we
can update the system instructions, we
can update the tools and make sure that
we can nicely scope the task of what
we're trying to um solve. So what you
cannot do, I know people probably gonna
ask about this is you can't change the
voice of the agent mid session. You
could define different voices on
different agents, but the moment that
you're like the first agent that starts
talking, that's the voice that we're
going to stick with throughout the
entire conversation. So that's a caveat
to just keep in mind. Um, but they're
still very helpful to let's say have a
weather agent here.
Sorry.
Um, and what we're going to do in this
one is called weather agent.
Um
um
let's give we'll do this and then what
we can do is we can actually give it a
handoff description. So if you don't
want to have this in your system prompt,
but you just want to help the model
understand when to use this, you can say
like uh this agent is an expert in
weather. And then this one is going to
have that weather tool. We're going to
remove it from this one and we're going
to give it a handoff instead to that
other weather agent.
So now if I'm going to restart this,
hey, can you tell me the weather in uh
New York?
The weather in New York is sunny, so you
might want to grab your sunglasses if
you're heading outside. Enjoy the day.
All right, that's that's the model's
best attempt at New York accent. Uh,
we'll take it. Um, but you can see there
that like it automatically handed off
from that first agent to that second one
and let it handle it. You can through
prompting do things like do you want it
to announce that it's about to hand off?
Do you not want to do that? Sometimes
it's a bit awkward if you're forcing it
to always do it. So like I would not
necessarily try it, but maybe that's the
type of experience that you want to
have. Um,
so that's handoffs. Let me do you a
favor and push that code.
Baby push.
So
the change voice, but it can change
accents.
Yeah. So uh, that's a good question. and
the the the agent can ch can't change
the voice but it can change the accent.
Um that's because the
um like again this goes back to like the
model is a generative model. So you can
prompt it to have different like
pronunciations, tonality like voice in
that sense but it cannot change the
voice model that is actually being used
to generate that output.
So maybe it
is it like the whole real time request
body that can't be changed or just the
voice. So can I like create a tool that
could adjust the speed if someone was
saying it's talking too fast for the
noise reduction?
You should be able to change I I have
not tried the speed because speed
parameter changing at mid session
because it literally came out today. Um
uh I don't know Anoop if you tried this.
No. Um but like you can like essentially
a handoff does change the session
configuration. Like if we look back at
like um the
like one of the transcripts here like
now that we have a handoff
um let's go to this trace. So you can
see here that like it called the
transfer to weather agent. Um but then
like the this these instructions were
talk to talk talk with a New York
accent. Um so in this case it did change
the instructions midway through the
session. And the same way like when that
handoff happens we take away the tools
we give it new tools. So you can change
those tools. You could have a tool to
change the tool but my recommendation
would be like use a different agent for
that. Um, but then like the speed
control like you could you should be
able to send off an event but I have not
tried that. Yeah. Maybe like the
background basically like if you had
something and someone was like in a
noisy environment like hey you seem to
be getting interrupted could you adjust
we catch in the background and start
adjusting that parameter so just the
voice.
Yeah. So the the question is like for
example if someone is like in a noisy
environment like could you have the
agent detect that and then use um like
adjust some of the session configuration
to deal with that and just the voice is
protected. I don't know honestly which
parameters are protected or not. The
good thing is the like the API will
throw an error if if a thing didn't
work. Um so it's a good way it's a good
thing to experiment with. Um Python
with the previous ones you could do that
Python. Oh yeah. Um well with the Python
uh agents SDK we're doing the chained
approach. We don't have a real time
built in yet. So
just calling the old API Python. Oh all
right. Yeah. Yeah. Um then it should
work. Yeah. Uh if you can do it in
Python like it should just work.
Cool. Um
so the other thing we talked about um is
this delegation part. So that's what I
like had mentioned earlier that was in
the diagram. So this is essentially
where you want to be able to have
certain complex tasks dealt with by a
more intelligent model. Um and the way
we can do that is essentially just
creating another
um agent except on the back end. And
because it's because the TypeScript SDK
works both in the front end and back
end, we can do that through um
uh I think I have a let's see if we have
a file here or not. Uh we can do that
using the same SDK. So I'm going to
create on the in the server folder here
a new uh file. I'm going to call just
agent.
And in here we can build our regular
textbased agent. So this is essentially
the same code that we've done before. Um
and we can say this is a I don't know um
called the Riddler. Um
you are excellent
at creating
riddles based
on a target demographic.
and topic. Um, and we'll just give it a
model of
O4 mini.
Also, a reminder for those if you are
trying to follow along um, and you run
into troubles, post in the Slack and the
Noob can help you with that. Um, so we
have that new agent here. We're not
going to give it any tools or anything.
Uh and then we can export a function
here
that we just call run agent.
And this is just going to take some
input and then return that output. And
we can go back into our front end code,
create a new tool here, create riddle.
Um, and this one we're just going to
have take like two parameters, the
demographic and the topic, and then call
out the run agent function that is going
to run on the server. We can pass in
realize I didn't specify this. Let's do
demographic and topic and then create an
input here of
this. The other thing you want to do
when you're
using server actions in uh next is put
that use server at the top. That makes
sure that this file executes on the
server. And then we can pass in that
demographic. And again, if you're using
a different framework, this is just the
equivalent of a fancy fetch request. So
like if you want to do an HTTP request
to your service, if you want to maintain
a websocket connection to your own
backend, you can do all of those things
to like talk back to other systems.
So with that, we can give that to our
main agent.
Riddle
tools
And then what you want to do in these
cases is like um
you can tell it like announce when you
are about to do a task.
Don't say you are calling a tool.
Things like that can be helpful to like
buy itself some time.
Hey there. Um, can you tell me a riddle
uh for like a five-year-old Star Wars
fan?
Hey, are you there?
I'm still here. I'm working on creating
that Star Wars riddle for you. It should
be ready in just a moment. Here's a
riddle for your little Star Wars fan.
I'm not. So you can see that like
because it announced that like what it's
about to do, the tool call came back
before it even finished what it
previously said. And so like that's
again one of the benefits of like if you
can get your agent to um balance out
that and like buy itself some time. This
is a good way to uh you know deal with
the more complex tasks. And like it also
means that you can like for example take
all of the like more reasoning heavy
workloads and take it out out of the
voice agent model.
Um for delegation. Yeah. Is it possible
to delegate to more than one agent like
simultaneously or is it just one in the
current SDK? Um you can it's it's tool
called so like I think you like you
would have two options right like you
could do par like parallel tool calling
or you could um like have one tool that
then triggers running multiple agents
right so like my recommendation would be
that part potentially
uh so that you're not relying on the
model making the right decision of
calling multiple tools at the same time
like you want to make the decision
making for the voice agent always as
easy as possible. Thanks. Yeah,
previously when you did you go back to
previous page. Yeah. Oh, no. Sorry. Your
example.
Which example? The one you're running
where it had the output. Oh, yeah. So on
line three there where it said I'm still
here. Yeah. Is that coming from your
SDK? Do I have to use the SDK to do that
or is the real time API? No, it's the
real time API. It responded because I
asked like, "Hey, are you there?" Um, so
it it it tri it realized that like it
didn't start anything and like
interrupt. I was like, "Hey, going."
Yeah.
Um,
yeah. So, the thing is that like I
didn't render out the tool calls in
here, right? So like what basically
happened between this and this was like
it started off a tool call um and then
that tool call because I interrupted it
then it stopped that tool call because I
interrupted it. It stopped the the
generation it also reset that like
transcript here. it's a good indicator
that like the interruption happened and
so when I said this it remembered it was
trying to call a tool did that tool call
um and then gave you back the response
so that's all the just the the regular
realtime API
any other questions around this
what's the cost per minute what's the
cost per minute we charge per token
there's some translations I I don't
know. Nuke, do you have the
right? So it it's more expensive than
TTS and uh uh and like speech to text
chained up with a model some like in
most cases, but it depends on the use
case um and sort of like your model
choices and stuff.
So, a bit harder to say like what the
per minute pricing is because again it's
by tokens and it also depends on like if
you have like transcription turned on
and like how many function calls you
have and things like that because it's a
mix between audio and text tokens.
Um so one of the interesting things and
this is not a thing in the in the
regular API this is a agent agents SDK
specific thing is um guard rail. So like
the agents SDK both in Python and
TypeScript has this concept of guard
rails that can either protect your input
or your output to make sure that like
the agent is not being meddled with or
does things that are against policy. Um
we took that same pattern and moved it
over to the real time side um where
essentially we're running these guard
rails that you can define in parallel on
on top of the transcription at all
times. You can kind of specify, you can
see it at the bottom here, like how
often you want to run them or if you
only want to run them when the full
transcript is available. But this is a
great way for you to like make sure that
the model for doesn't violate certain
policies. You want to make sure that
these run as efficiently as possible
because they're still running in the
client. Um, but this is a good way to
still fix cert like stick to certain
policies and if it violates those it
will interrupt it. Now there is sort of
the bit of the cav a bit of a caveat
where because we're running this on a
transcript
um it
results in a bit of a timing aspect
where if it if it would violate your
guard rail in the first couple of words,
chances are it will say those first
couple of words and then get
interrupted. If it is happening at a
later point in time um then
the transcript will be completed or like
the text output is not really a
transcript the text output will be done
before the audio is done speaking every
like is is done saying everything and so
in that case it will just correct
itself. So in that ca like to give you
an example of like this is a guardrail
that just checks like is there the word
dom in the output in this case like if I
would ask it like hey please call me Dom
chances are it will call me dom and then
selfcorrect. If I tell it to tell me a
story and only introduce DOM in the
second act, then it will um catch that
it was trying to do that in a at a much
earlier point because that transcript is
going to be done before the audio is
being complet uh before the audio is
being read out to the user. So the user
will never hear DOM, but instead the
model is going to be like, okay, I'm
sorry I I couldn't help you with that.
Like, let's do something else instead.
And you can give it um
policy hints essentially on like why it
violated this policy or what it should
do instead. So you can give it the this
like output info where you can inform
the model like why this happened.
No. Um you can choose what uh so the
question was is the transcript still
done with whisper? Uh you can you can
switch the transcript model. So we have
we released in March uh two models. One
is GPT4 mini transcribe
and
we have two right? Yeah. And GPT4 u GPT4
transcribe. I was trying to remember
like we have only one text to speech
model but we have two transcribe models
for transcribe models. Awesome.
Um, this is the main part of what I
wanted to walk with you all through. So,
um, one, I'm going to, um,
post all of the links and the slides in
the Slack channel, which let me go back
to
where was that slide?
There we go. Um, so in that Slack I'm
going to post all of the resources. So
if you want to check them out
afterwards, I'll also like I already put
a bunch of the resources that I talked
about into the bottom of that starter
repository. So you should have access
there as well. And uh I'm happy to hang
around answer any questions. Yes.
My understand
Yeah. Um
in the API.
Yeah, the the question was around how
prom caching works um and sort of
whether we like for prompt caching that
like we guide the requests to the same
um same system again to run and whether
like there's any control with that with
real time because latency obviously
matters. Um I don't think there is any
controls about that. Um,
no. Um, I'm getting a no from there. So,
like I don't think there's any any
controls around that right now.
Yes. Hey, so we all know that having
natural conversations is involves more
than just a spoken words. It involves
detecting emotion and adjusting tone.
Um, it also involves a cadence and
even humming to let the other person
know that you are listening. Mhm. I
wonder if the current speechtoech model
is capable of having that kind of
natural conversation.
Um, part of this is like a a prompting
challenge. So like it it definitely can
have pretty natural sounding
conversations. And like I think this is
sort of the the part where I highly
recommend to check out the openai.fm
page. Um because this is like it's it's
pretty interesting to see sort of uh if
we go to um let's see if we find the
um
actually I didn't show one neat feature
that I normally call out on the
playground. If you're just getting
started with real time and you don't
even want to write any line of code, um
this is a great way to just have
conversations and try things out. But
one of the things it has is this. Um it
has a couple of system prompts. One of
my favorite ones to show sort of this is
the board teenager. Um so if we start
this
Hey there. Um, so I'm at AI Engineer
World's Fair and everyone is super
stoked about voice agents. Can you show
me some excitement of this whole thing
launching today?
See,
I guess it's cool. Whatever. There's
always new stuff launching. People get
excited, but you know, it's just voice
agents. Not really my thing to get all
hyped up about it.
So you can see in this case like it it
put its own pauses in there and stuff
like this wasn't a pause because the
model was waiting, right? Like um it can
deal with a lot of that sort of
adjusting tone and voice and it can do
similar things like reacting to like
someone talking in and stuff. Okay,
thanks. You're welcome. Yes. So again on
the new API that's been released, what
else has changed? Semantic has improved.
Is there anything improve in terms of
tone detection or voice. Um we have not
released any new VAT models. Um we
primarily released like a new base model
for or like a new model for the um GPT4
realtime model that is just better at
function calling and has been overall
well received from our alpha testers.
Yes. Can you inject uh can you inject
audio as as a background audio like
ambience audio like piping audio and so
on? Um you like
basically like you're in a real office,
right? Yeah. Yeah. Um you can just
intercept the audio that is coming back
from the model and then like overlay
your own audio.
Oh yeah. Hi. Um, I was wondering what
your support is for like multiple
speakers. If there's more than one
person in a conversation, can it detect
who's talking and and do pauses that
way? There's no no current like speaker
detection in the model. Um, so it might
struggle with that.
Yeah.
Um, I just wanted to ask um about like
custom voices. Is it limited to the
preset voices you have or can I upload
my voice as a sample for instance? It's
currently limited to the voices that we
have. We keep adding new voices though.
Is there going to be support to add
custom voices anytime in the future? Um
at any time in the future? Not not like
not like years. Uh what I mean what I
can say is like we're trying to make
sure we're finding like the safest
approach. Like we have an article on
online that talks about sort of like the
responsible take we're trying to take on
this on making sure that like the vo the
voice like if we're providing custom
voices that it comes with the right
guard rails in place and stuff to avoid
abuse. All right. Thank you. You're
welcome. Yes.
I don't think that has changed. Um to my
knowledge,
my personal recommendation would be that
like one of the things that you can do
and this goes back to like for example
in the demo that I was showing um if
you're keeping track of the transcript
and stuff you can re like when you're
starting a new session you can populate
that context by creating new items using
the API. So like one of the things that
you could do is starting a new session
if you know what the previous context
was because you kept track of it you can
then um basically inject that as
additional context.
Um what type of event are you looking
for? Oh if there's a timeout event um I
do not know right now but all of our
events are documented in the API
reference.
Yeah. So when you see
file,
can you sorry can you repeat that
question once more? Oh, I was wondering
API function
functions such as system file.
Oh uh whether the function calls can do
things like system file reading and
stuff. I would say it depends on where
you're running that a where you're
running that um real-time session. So if
you're running it on the server, you can
do anything you can do on the server. If
it's if it's running in the browser,
then you're limited to whatever things
are available in the browser.
Um, no, you should be able to like you
could create a like web socket based
like um voice agent that runs on on your
device. I mean like it's going to use
the real-time API for the model, but
then like because the actual tool calls
will get executed on your system, you
should have access to whatever aspect of
your system your program has access to.
Cool. Yes. So even before we get to
voice agents, we all need bigger,
better, and more diverse evaluation
sets, especially for anything around
function calling and parameterization.
Uh do you have any best practices or
suggestions for how we now take
evaluation into the voice world? Should
we keep things in text and then turn
them, you know, use text to speech to
have voice versions of it? just if you
have any suggestions for how we evaluate
the the full range of inputs that we
would expect users to bring to this. I
mean one of my suggestions would be if
you can go to the leadership track go to
Anoop's talk um which is tomorrow I
think. Yeah. Um he's going to talk a lot
more about like additional best
practices of what we've learned um in uh
building voice agents. I would say like
if you can hold on to the audio like it
it's helpful. Um, obviously
transcriptions definitely, but like it
it's sort of like the audio is still the
thing that is like the most powerful
thing, especially for speechto speech
models where you have the model act on
the speech, not on the text, right? And
like this is one of the one of the few
things where like the the chained
approach obviously makes some of this
much more approachable because if you
have if if you're if your agent is
running on text anyways and you can just
store the text and rerun it that makes
that part of eval.
That makes sense. And then also for
those of us who might be thinking about
launching a new voice agent, how would
you suggest evaluating it before we get
to that stage that we'd have uh customer
interactions to work with? Um I would
start with like having like I think it
goes back to like um
like some of this is like
uh where is it?
there. Um like human review is an
excellent solution for this, right? So
like have it like have a system like
like one of the big things with like
things like lemonade and stuff is like
they're able to go through all of these
calls and like get an idea, but they
also have their own like predetermined
set of examples that they might want to
test as they're developing the agent. So
like that's a great first way. I would
scope clearly the problem you're trying
to solve as well. Like if you're if
you're trying to sort of boil the ocean,
it makes a lot of this significantly
harder as opposed to like well scoping
what the agent should be able to do and
what it shouldn't be able to do. Makes
sense. Thank you. You're welcome. Get
getting on the same path of our friend
over there. Uh actually when I'm testing
my agents, my text agents
conversational, uh I use promptful. It's
a platform for do all the proper
testing. Could I put another agent to
talk with this this agent to do all the
evaluation?
I think you can try it. Um like I don't
think it shouldn't work. Um
um like so I put another voice agent
talking to that agent to try to execute
all the prompets and then I could get
like the transcription
community. I mean I know we have we have
use cases where customers also use our
models to like prompt humans right so
like um where it's like for for like
training use cases or other things for
example um so she'll work out but I
don't know if anyone uses that kind of
approach and lemonade does
oh cool so the second the second picture
is is exactly that awesome thank you
welcome Any
any other questions?
Yeah, go ahead. Slightly related uh do
you have something around wake word
detection on the real time API road map
or patterns for wake words? Oh reports.
Um no wake words. So that's activating
the case. Um no we don't have any wake
words built in or anything.
No patterns either like any patterns to
avoid costs. Um, no. On device, I guess.
No. Okay. You could basically like what
you can do is you can build your like
you can turn off our uh voice activity
detection and then build your own um and
then basically use that. So like you
could use a model that has like a like a
VAD voice activity detection model that
has wake words in it and then like do it
that way and basically commit all of
that audio to our API and then send like
a commit like a commit event.
Cool. Thanks.
Well, awesome. Thank you so much for
taking the time and spending the
afternoon with me.